[Music]
20 international chess professionals
converge here in st. Louis for the 2017
winter chess classic hello chess fans
and welcome to round number five we're
at the halfway point for the winter
chess classic we go into hump day with
David Howell in the lead in group a his
counterpart in Group B is Andre bearish
pullets who also leads by half a point
these players will earn top level
tournament experience but also there's a
twenty-thousand-dollar prize fund at
stake the winner of group a next five
thousand dollars the winner of groupie
that's four thousand dollars in Group A
we have Grandmaster samsa beyond who
still holds the record for the youngest
American Grandmaster ever today he had a
game that well maybe not maybe you'd
like to forget after today we'll take a
look at it against Grandmaster eep atop
so Sam you had the white pieces take us
through this game it looked like you
were winning for a while yeah those have
been doing that I couldn't find you in
here but I found anything a good move
Bishop f5 defending a very strong 77 and
what has ideas the worksheet now winning
material so here I think that about half
an hour like three minutes and each was
most practicable h6 which loses but
worked out in the game the moon's I was
considered well to this thinking with my
BD seven and here i found nice one
Bishop f4 night except for Bishop h7 can
get shape that of savage engage 79 th
and if you place quindi file Knesset
only tears 95 I think rook takes off a
queen takes off a check kyndra 28 and
what way
if 96 h three similar GH quindi a check
Queenie 8 and you can go Knights
executed morning the most virulent move
forward Knight f6 which I expected but
hereafter we move like Bishop b2
threatening Bishop of 694 o.h files and
what should be close 22 so if I'd h6
which loses but playing games by time
kind of helps him 95 study it's so
tempting i am i didn't really consider
anything else is 94 might have stirred
my shifting g6r cheesy they're probably
all good but I'm really i think this is
the best most can pick up some Queen h5
that here i miss this one group she ate
it just ends the game of needles and so
there's nothing to do if you take a ship
CA I don't even have to take that I
think a check just made right there just
me if she takes the same thing here
takes check
I just noticed that is equal material ha
and he's getting made it so I said I'm
done a picture I just win the peace back
and a scoop of the limit yeah so that's
really not not difficult at all ok I
think lynch mob which is kind of natural
there's two ways of defending your night
keep like 26 if you guys might be seven
push up g 696 look up for King g81 g6
wet wins because the d7 policy yeah here
at Queen six chapter in my book Quincy
694 would listen you're right about
major on clock so actually right there
like 8-9 winning most here's the play
Bishop b2 which allows my ps4 then I
move it away and they allowed him to
jump that for anything going to Bishop
b2 is probably the nicest flirting
Bishop a five and then deflecting the
Queen if night go to Eastern I still
have this paper because we text I should
be six and I took up the queen but most
like g3 Wayne stopping night of form
they're not that trivial but they should
although I chose Bishop e2 which throws
away to win now here goes maybe a 494
good you food and he spent pretty much
almost always time on finding the draw
and you sure you want to buy h5 but
there is nice when you check
check now chicken h5 and luggage for me
huh
but he found ridiculous range curve with
holes again yeah I now I took Bishop 3
696 Queen a fat check King g8 now White
has many options but none of them actual
ring and for example if I take g6 can
probably take a bit too but you can also
take here can gauge shape and the bishop
side stage 7 and you just defend
everything now I'm starting late and you
can't take the Queen because of the pin
but he has 21 check changing queens on
winning the king himself this no he
can't take the review books of meta
fixture and Korean 78 so another fix
check GS Queen TV g6 if queen e six th-7
check here I thought this wind initially
but then I saw couldn t one shot Quinn
g6 check and I lose the bishop now so I
took on g6 which should be seven
check-in age 7 and now I got to move
forward and Elizabeth attached here
because I throw away the way um yeah
Quint adda if I go route g4 it just
gives check and take 77 check king be a
chase and I'm just losing because I
can't take another 6 226 so that's like
28 and he found the draw pretty quickly
quindi one check tonight row we take the
rook this is what I calculated initially
I between seven and he just has no
perpetual or no way to threaten late for
example ng5 series 21 King gauge to
Bishop takes f.3d a queen queen see to
threatening mate now I've quintic g7
queen of six make myself if you guys
Queen see to it the same thing I just
queen if you buy screwed c6f 326 now
it's important to protecting each one
because if King gauge till he has Queen
takes lead to be shipped accessories
check
Queen check sure and because I have an
extra credit he has no professor
Elijah's block on the phone so the draw
was kundi one check can gauge to Queen
d6 check and if I go s4 which I thought
work he has Queen d2 and an actual
relationship so really nice because I've
so much extra material but nothing to do
that can be so sick I can't stop quickly
g-tube if I go g3 to mate on this
diagonal and if I try being fancy with a
blue cast for Queen to accept 14g one
now has Queen g5 and again I don't like
up and soft nature so that's pretty much
it my best chance of percocet winning on
the spot and pretty simple well so Sam
was it at move 40 when you kind of took
a breath and realize that the wind had
slipped away yes so how would you
evaluate your situation so far your two
and a half 45 we still have four rounds
left to go what are your feelings on the
tournament this far I think I've been
pretty well with my nutrition isn't too
good I messed up to a winning position
compostable escort hacen Josephine
but overall I think extreme pretty
efficient well I wish you the best in
the upcoming around Sam thank you for
joining me let's take a look at how
everyone else did after all draws today
in Group A thus the standings stay the
same just the numbers changed by half a
point but remember not all drawers have
to be boring like you just saw with that
SEBI on epitope game the game of the day
for round six on Thursday March 16th
well we're going to stay with David
Howell as he has the white pieces
against Vladimir feo josei of sitting
amongst the top of the best in Group B
is chess commentator broadcaster
journalist Grandmaster Christian Carillo
thank you for joining me it's not a good
40 advising yeah absolutely now what
kind of buddies we're not going to
pretend like we're not I mean we were a
went to the World Championship together
and we showed historical moment yeah
yeah great roomie and today a good game
take us through this game we played as
white in Group B yes this is the second
time I've I'm facing Robert I think the
first time it was in the world
championship under 10 years old I
remember he had a very mean mug and that
didn't change but he's a very good
friend what I tried here is somehow find
the best way to UM to get my roots with
temple on the Kings side the thing is
that at the beginning the first few
moves I had to spend a lot of time he
had the easy moves at this moment we I
had maybe like six minutes left if i
remember correctly and he had 15 minutes
left nevertheless in this position is he
who has to make the decisions pretty
much at every move he had so many
options you can play the Queen on 85 he
can play Queen d3 Queen d2 queen bee too
there's plenty of options available to
him and when you have little time and
you don't really know which one which
one is the best it becomes a little bit
difficult so he played quindi 30 we
discussed a little bit and I think we
need to perhaps is a little bit better
to get his screen back to
g5 never let you play queen bee treat
rock fd1 Queen at five rooks III my rook
is trying to swing over the third-ranked
and go to f3 double up on the F filed
and move my bishop an attack on f7 and I
thought I have quite quite good
compensation for my loss on especially
because of the time situation this is
this is a practical position and
whenever your long time you know nine
nine out of ten I think white in a
practical game should have the advantage
I'm pretty sure the computer is going to
say no you're you're wrong and black is
much better because of the pawn up but i
felt quite good at this model 97 Brooke
f3 my moves worries his moves were a
little bit difficult so I got to build
up some sort of time differential here
rook f 1 f 5 interesting moves perhaps
not the most precise and now I have to
make a decision also i can i can just
play Bishop f3 and try to keep the
structure like this or I can take on f6
allow his night to come to become a
little bit more active but in the same
time activate my bishop get a very very
nice square on e5 for my bishop so this
is what i did i took on f6 and i take
the six Bishop d3 now my bishop is
heading towards the e5 square very
central e 5 and then root g three
potentially is going to create a lot of
problems for his King Queen d2 now if i
go Bishop b5 the problem is I am
defending the d4 pawn but he's going to
play Knight g4 and I'm not really sure
what I can do next so instead of that I
played root root be one Queen g5 and I
think this is the critical moment when
probably am I made an unexpected move
which which creates serious trouble for
him especially with low time initially I
want to play Bishop b5
but I soon realized that after Knight g4
my idea was to play a root g3 and now
after Queen aged white Bishop takes g7
king tigey g7 h3 recaptured the night on
g4 and then just have a much better
position because of my optimal King
safety nevertheless the problem is after
Bishop g7 I'm simply dropping the pond
on h2 with the check Queen takes 3 3
game is over Black is winning so I bet I
almost touch the piece I didn't I didn't
play be 55 and then I thought okay I
should do some prophylaxis play each 3g
foursquare 1490s extremely extremely
powerful so if i take that away from
from him my king becomes a little bit
safer because i can always go King h2
and then I can just simply play Bishop
b5 of g3 so he played b5 Queen 86 beat
xt for Bishop b5 and now with with very
low maybe like a couple of seconds left
on the clock late King a trade in the
post-mortem we decided that night each
five is actually the best move again I
don't know what the computer is saying
so i might be wrong but it's quite an
inch it's quite a funny move because
this is a bad square for tonight it's
completely limited by the bishop only
five now nevertheless it keeps control
over the g3 square and at some point
you're the black is going to try to
exchange the rules on the f5 there's
very very complicated variations I'm not
going to go through all of those he
played a move King a trade after which i
think my position is simply just winning
rook f1 ruka fate Queen goes to be seven
that's why I didn't take on on on b5
because I wanted to shift my queen
towards his King and also keep control
over the a8 rook c3 roof g3 Queen h6
Bishop before now the g7 point cannot be
covered anymore and his position
collapses he tried his last trick let's
say you be
hvac to Bishop f4 the bishop on f4 is
returning now the thing is if he takes
on therefore i'm not going to take back
and allow him to promote this might be
winning as well but there is a much
easier way to end the game and that is
Queen takes g7 so he doesn't even have
these tactics and he played the move
Knight h5 now i take the Queens rook
takes Knight takes 2-3 King you want and
he resigned because of taking here I
simply grab this piece with the checks
then protect against see one Queen and
the game is over very cool well
congratulations on your victory over
Robert S thank my former US Championship
competitor competitor for a few years
and well there's four rounds left who do
you have left to play in this tournament
which game are you looking forward to
most that's a provocative question it is
it's very very deep you know it's a
provocative question i think i have been
fine gold bearish bowlers who i believe
if if you want his game against
alejandro we should be in the lead so
Alejandro and run buzz very very tough
opponents all four top seeds most of
them Alejandro is coming after a very
very successful I offload open so I'm
actually looking forward to the game
against thing we have kind of
competitive dynamics between us we like
to trash talk a little bit Alejandro
definitely has a better score he he beat
me like three times I only made the drop
and he's going to have white stuff but
I'm looking forward to that is going to
be a fun fun little sure it's going to
be a lot of trash talk on the line you
know so absolutely absolutely the yeah
there's a lot of tension building up
there well sitting right now as we speak
at the top of the heap and Group B
congratulations again and let's take a
look after the entire round is over
we'll reveal what the standings are
after five in Group B so carrilla beat s
but baarish pullets also beat Ramirez so
Andre bars pullets
the Ukrainian still sits at an amazing
four and a half out of five the game of
the day for Thursday March 16th in Group
B is quite obvious the two frontrunners
Andre bearish bullets as white taking on
Christian corolla with black the 2017
winter chess classic runs every day
through sunday March 19th rounds begin
at one p.m. each day except for the
final round see the games live as they
happen on us chess champ calm and chest
24.com